la première tv qui vous avez couché
c'est à quel âge on va tout reprendre
depuis le début j'ai eu c'était
tacchella et en plus vous zappez doc
gynéco j'ai quand même un monde
alors non il accroche et puis la moindre
idée de ce assez incroyable et moi mais
vous êtes qui gyneco j'aimerais que tu
nous racontes ta première fois sur
jeanne mas parce que ça je pensais sans
moi doc gynéco
vous pouvez nous raconter votre première
fois parce que votre première fois vous
l'avez fait sur le titre de jeanne mas
toute première fois oui et non en fait
c'est une chanson qui a voyagé dans le
temps et qui m'a permise en quelque
sorte de 200 me rendre compte de
peut-être il serait possible que j'ai
été inspiré par votre titre parce que
lorsqu'on m'a appelé qu'on m'a dit oui
quand était la première fois je ne
savais pas que vous veniez et j'ai dit
bah alors toute première fois on n'est
pas l'ordre quand j'ai appelé indiqué
pour que pourquoi on te demander ta
première fois tu n'as pas demandé qui
était l'invité je savais pas que c'est
acquis chanter cette chanson c'est que
c'était black m
[Rires]
alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous
raconter d'autres votre première fois il
faudrait que je puisse m'en souvenais
c'est comme kelly elle m'a dit je me
rappelle pas de la première fois j'ai
fait l'amour m'a dit je prie je me
rappelle que de ce que j'ai mangé ce
soir là je me souviens pas de la
première fois
c'est tout de ma gueule se trouve en
plein air mais tu t'en souviens bien sûr
je m'en souviens à moi ma peine amende
gt on veut savoir j'étais jeune en train
d'inventer avec une sublime mannequin
sud américaine gina que j'embrasse non
c'est à oran sans l'appeler orangina
parce qu'on la supprime beaucoup
elle raconte la deuxième fois la
dernière fois bon peut-être que c'était
avec n'ont même pas parce que la
première fille avec laquelle j'étais
j'avais pas couché avec elle
d'accord c'est la première tv qui vous
avez couché c'est à quel âge on va tout
reprendre depuis le début je n'étais pas
qu'elle ait en plus vous zappez doc
gynéco j'ai quand même un monde proche
et plus la moindre idée de ce assez
incroyable et moi mais vous êtes qui
mais sans rigoler frérot tu as fait des
tests de mémoire c'est un truc que j'ai
occulté
est ce que tu te souviens de ce que tu
as fait alors on va les plus impactants
on va juste à tester ta mémoire ou bu
toute cette histoire de première fois de
manière non pas du tout
qu'as tu fait nous sommes jeudi que tu
fais jeudi dernier bon alors je crois
qu'on a tous dit se souvient pas de ce
qu'il a fait jeudi dernier et j'en ai
mal je vais poser une autre question
qu'as tu fait hier hier après midi
en fait je n'arrive qu'à avancer
j'arrive pas dire tu te souviens même
pas de ce que tu as fait hier après-midi
4k tubulures après midi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]